vrai que c'est pas facile parce que au
lido s'était tourné au lido avec à 1200
personnes nous avait dit vous inquiétez
pas il y aura des spots qui vont
éclaboussé les yeux des gens et veyran
rien plus d artifice des taux je peux
vous dire que a abandonné les artifices
ya deux artifices comme ça et puis à
bruno guillon qui en plein milieu comme
ça alors pour c'est pour la bonne cause
donc benjamin gille on compte sur vous
les chirurgiens des leçons sur scène si
vous enlevez bien sûr tout vêtement
sauve aux sous vêtements
on donne 1500 euros pour la recherche de
[Applaudissements]
la vérité soit connue malgré tout 500
morts tu vas leur corps
[Applaudissements]
oui
d'autres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mentalement
oui
[Applaudissements]
je
célébrant bien vu
[Applaudissements]